tout en essayant de diriger mon entreprise.
Une fois, j’ai plaisanté
que j’avais, à contrecœur,
présenté mon projet à toute ma famille, amis, collègues, investisseurs et VC
de ce côté du Mississippi.
Eh bien, en parlant à tous ces investisseurs,
j’ai constaté quelque chose d’intéressant.
On me posait une série de questions bien différente qu’à mon cofondateur.
On m’a interrogée sur tout ce qui pouvait mal tourner dans l’entreprise
menant à des pertes pour les investisseurs,
alors que mon cofondateur était questionné sur le potentiel de notre société
à maximiser les gains des investisseurs,
soit tout ce qui pourrait bien se passer pour l’entreprise.
On lui a demandé combien de nouveaux clients nous allions apporter,
alors qu’on me demandait comment conserver ceux que l’on avait déjà.
En tant que PDG, j’ai trouvé ça plutôt étrange.
En fait, j’avais même l’impression d’halluciner.
Puis j’ai fini par relativiser en pensant :
« Peut-être que c’est la manière dont je me présente »
ou « C’est quelque chose de propre à ma start-up ».
Des années plus tard, j’ai fait le choix difficile de quitter ma start-up
afin de réaliser un rêve de toute une vie, celui d’obtenir mon doctorat.
C’est à Columbia que j’ai eu connaissance d’une théorie de psychologie sociale
établie par le professeur Tory Higgins, nommée « orientation régulatrice »
qui opère une distinction entre deux orientations motivationnelles
de promotion et de prévention.
Le concept de promotion se focalise sur les gains
et valorise les espoirs, les réussites et besoins d’évolution professionnelle,
tandis que le concept de prévention porte sur les pertes
et valorise la sécurité, la responsabilité et la protection.
Dans le meilleur des cas, être orienté prévention
vise uniquement à maintenir le statu quo,
ce qui nous fait faire du sur-place pour assurer notre survie,
alors qu’être orienté promotion nous fait avancer dans la bonne direction.
Il s’agit seulement de découvrir jusqu’où nous pouvons aller.
Puis j’ai eu une révélation lorsque j’ai réalisé que
ce concept de promotion
se rapprochait beaucoup des questions posées à mon cofondateur,
tandis que le concept de prévention s’apparentait plus aux miennes.
Étant étudiante en entrepreneuriat,
je me suis attaquée aux recherches sur le financement des start-ups
et j’ai découvert un fossé considérable
entre les montants des fonds soulevés par les fondateurs homme et femme.
Même si 38 % des entreprises américaines ont été fondées par des femmes,
elles ne reçoivent que 2 % des financements.
Ce qui m’a fait réfléchir :
et si ce fossé n’était pas dû à un contraste majeur
au sein des entreprises créées par des hommes et des femmes ?
Et si les femmes obtenaient moins de fonds que les hommes
simplement à cause des différentes questions qui leur sont posées ?
Après tout, pour financer des entreprises à risque,
les entrepreneurs doivent convaincre
de l’ambition de leur start-up.
Il ne suffit pas de démontrer
que vous ne perdrez pas l’argent de l’investisseur.
Il est alors logique que les femmes reçoivent moins de fonds que les hommes
si elles s’impliquent
dans des dialogues axés sur la prévention plutôt que sur la promotion.
J’ai eu l’opportunité de tester cette hypothèse
sur des sociétés de nature et aux besoins de financement
similaires au fil des ans,
lors du concours de subventions connu sous le nom de Start-up Battlefield,
que TechCrunch organise à New York
depuis son lancement en 2010.
TechCrunch est largement considéré comme l’endroit idéal pour lancer une start-up,
et certains de ses participants sont devenus célèbres depuis,
tels que Dropbox, Fitbit, et Mint.
Tous ont présenté devant certains des VC les plus en vue.
Malgré les ressemblances entre les sociétés dans mon jeu de données,
celles menées par des hommes ont récolté cinq fois plus de fonds
que celles menées par des femmes.
Ce qui m’a rendue désireuse
de savoir ce qui entraîne cette disparité entre les sexes.
Il m’a fallu du temps,
mais j’ai obtenu toutes les vidéos de présentation
et de sessions d’entretien de TechCrunch
puis je les ai fait transcrire.
J’ai d’abord examiné les transcriptions
en chargeant un lexique d’orientation régulatrice
dans le logiciel Linguistic Inquiry and Word Count (LIWC).
Il génère la fréquence d’apparition
de propos de promotion et de prévention dans la transcription.
Pour la méthode suivante,
j’ai fait programmer manuellement chaque question-réponse
par le laboratoire de recherche Tory Higgins à Columbia.
Quel que soit le sujet,
une intention peut s’inscrire dans le concept de promotion
ou de prévention.
Prenons la question sur la clientèle citée plus tôt.
Une question « promotion » serait :
« Combien de nouveaux clients projetez-vous d’acquérir cette année ? »
alors que qu'en « prévention », elle devient :
« Comment comptez-vous préserver votre clientèle existante ? »
Au même moment,
j’ai également recueilli les informations de base
sur les start-ups et entrepreneurs susceptibles d’affecter leur financement,
comme l’âge, la nature et les besoins de financement de la start-up,
ainsi que l’expérience de l’entrepreneur,
afin d’utiliser ces données comme points de contrôle pour mon analyse.
La toute première chose que j’ai constatée
est qu’il n’y a aucune différence
dans la manière dont les entrepreneurs présentent leur société.
Autrement dit, hommes et femmes entrepreneurs
adoptent aussi bien les notions de promotion que de prévention
lors de leur pitch.
Alors, puisque cette inégalité ne vient pas des entrepreneurs,
je me suis penchée sur le cas des investisseurs
en analysant les six minutes d’entretien
auxquelles les entrepreneurs se livrent à la suite de leur pitch.
En examinant près de 2 000 questions-réponses
de ces échanges,
mes deux méthodes montrent clairement
que chez les entrepreneurs, les hommes ont des questions axées promotion,
pendant que les femmes sont testées sur la prévention.
C’est même plus éloquent en chiffres, car cela représente respectivement
67 % des questions posées aux hommes,
et 66 % de celles posées aux femmes.
Ce qui m’a particulièrement interpellée,
c’est que j’espérais voir les femmes VC
agir de la même façon les hommes VC.
La théorie « qui se ressemble s’assemble » étant omniprésente dans les médias
et dans la documentation sur le financement, je m’attendais à ce que
les VC masculins encouragent les entrepreneurs
par des questions « promotion »,
et idem pour les femmes VC envers les entrepreneuses.
Mais en réalité, l’ensemble des VC font preuve du même sexisme tacite
observé dans leurs entretiens usant de l’orientation régulatrice,
menés avec les candidats et les candidates.
Les femmes VC posent donc des questions de promotion aux entrepreneurs
puis interrogent les entrepreneuses en termes de prévention,
à l’instar des VC hommes.
Dès lors que les hommes et femmes VC
exhibent cette discrimination implicite,
quel est l’impact, le cas échéant, sur le financement des start-ups ?
Mes recherches prouvent que l’impact est conséquent.
Les questions orientées des investisseurs
ont non seulement prédit le rendement des start-ups
lors du concours de TechCrunch,
mais aussi le montant des fonds qu’elles ont levés sur le marché libre.
Ces start-up à qui l’on a surtout posé des questions de promotion
ont récolté sept fois plus d’argent
que celles interrogées dans la prévention.
Mais je suis allée plus loin.
Je suis passée aux réponses des entrepreneurs
et j’ai noté qu’ils les ajustent habilement
en fonction des questions posées.
Ce qui signifie que l’orientation de la question
prédétermine celle de la réponse.
Cela a beau nous paraître sensé,
il y a de fâcheuses répercussions lorsqu’il s’agit de financement VC.
En fin de compte,
un entrepreneur se voit interrogé dans le concept de promotion,
ce qui lui offre l’avantage d’être fortement associé au profit
rien qu’en s’adaptant aux questions ;
pendant qu’une entrepreneuse interrogée dans l’idée de prévention
se lie de façon aggravante et malgré elle
aux pertes financières, en s’adaptant pourtant elle aussi...
Ces réponses suscitent ensuite d’autres questions biaisées des VC,
et l’ensemble de ces questions-réponses alimentent ce cycle de préjugés
qui ne fait que perpétuer la disparité entre les sexes.
Plutôt déprimant, pas vrai ?
Heureusement, il y a une lueur d’espoir dans mes découvertes.
Les entrepreneurs audacieux qui ont réussi à détourner
les questions de prévention avec des réponses axées sur la promotion
ont levé 14 fois plus de fonds
que ceux qui n'ont pas adapté leurs réponses.
Ce qui veut dire que si l’on vous posait une question
sur la défense de la part de marché de votre start-up,
vous feriez mieux de centrer votre réponse
autour de la taille et du potentiel de croissance du marché global,
au lieu de simplement décrire comment vous protégeriez votre propre part.
Alors si l’on me pose cette question,
je dirais :
« On s’aventure sur un marché si vaste et si actif
qui ne manquera pas d’attirer de nouveaux venus.
Nous prévoyons de remporter une part croissante du marché
en exploitant nos atouts inégalés. »
J’ai subtilement réorienté la conversation vers le profit.
Ces résultats sont assez fascinants pour les start-ups lancées à TechCrunch,
mais les données recueillies sur le terrain ne révèlent qu’une corrélation
entre l’orientation motivationnelle et le financement.
J’ai donc cherché à savoir
si cette nuance dans l’orientation motivationnelle
influe réellement sur le financement
en menant une expérience contrôlée
sur les business angels et les personnes lambda.
Au cœur d’une simulation de l’environnement TechCrunch,
les participants ont écouté quatre extraits de six minutes chacun,
contenant 10 entretiens
façonnés par le langage de promotion et de prévention.
Puis je leur ai demandé d’attribuer un montant
à chaque entreprise comme bon leur semblait.
Mes résultats expérimentaux ont étayé mes constats faits sur le terrain.
Les entrepreneurs qui ont répondu à des questions de promotion
ont perçu le double d’argent
de ceux à qui l’on a posé des questions de prévention.
Ce qui est d’autant plus encourageant,
c’est que ceux qui ont osé changer le cours de l’entretien
lorsqu’ils étaient confrontés à des questions de prévention,
ont reçu un financement plus élevé de tous les participants VC.
Alors, avis aux entrepreneuses qui m’entendent,
voilà quelques conseils sur ce que vous pourriez faire.
Le premier est d’identifier la question qui vous est posée.
Êtes-vous confrontée à une question de prévention ?
Si tel est le cas, répondez-y quoiqu’il arrive,
mais recentrez simplement votre réponse sur la promotion
dans le but d’amasser des montants plus élevés pour financer vos start-ups.
Cependant, la triste réalité
est que les hommes et femmes évaluant les start-ups
font tous deux preuve du même sexisme implicite
dans leurs entretiens,
privilégiant malencontreusement les entrepreneurs
homme plutôt que femme.
Alors, aux investisseurs qui m’entendent,
je dirais que vous avez ici l’opportunité
d’aborder les entretiens de manière plus juste ;
pas seulement afin de faire ce qu’il s’impose,
mais pour que vous puissiez améliorer la qualité de votre prise de décision.
En mettant équitablement en avant
le potentiel de rentabilité des start-up et leurs risques de pertes,
vous permettez à toutes les start-ups de briller
et maximisez, au passage, les bénéfices.
Aujourd’hui, je peux être cette fille
longeant la piscine,
et tirant la sonnette d’alarme
parce qu’il se passe quelque chose sous la surface.
Ensemble, nous avons le pouvoir de briser ce cycle
de sexisme sous-jacent dans le financement de start-ups.
Offrons aux start-ups les plus prometteuses,
peu importe qu’elles soient dirigées par un homme ou une femme,
une chance de s’en sortir, grandir et prospérer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)